I've been a writer all my life and I've
run with shoes pretty much all that time
but as a result of this research I
thought I should try barefoot running
and I actually have to say I really
enjoyed it it's been a lot of fun humans
have been running for at least two
million years and of course for most of
that time humans were running barefoot
and modern running shoes were actually
only invented in the mid-1970s so we
have this idea now that you know in
order to run you need you need you know
all you need a pair of shoes it's a
common statement right well actually
that's not true you don't need shoes you
just need feet there's probably two
stages in the evolution of the foot
initially the foot evolved for walking
and also to climb trees but at some
point in human evolution we think around
2 million years ago there was a big
environmental change in Africa and the
woodlands started disappearing and the
savannas started growing and at that
point new foods started appearing and
one of them of course was was meat for
all these ungulates out there on the
grasslands and in order to become a
hunter I think humans started to evolve
running and what we're good at is it
running it running at speeds that make
animals gallop and if you do that in the
heat for a long period of time that
animal will overheat because quadrupeds
cannot pant and gallop at the same time
so imagine you're chasing a gazelle or a
kudu or some big animal if you can chase
that animal make that animal gallop for
10 to 15 minutes you've got dinner
we wanted to figure out how people ran
without shoes before the shoe was
invented because people have been
running for millions of years and we're
really we weren't really sure what
happens when when barefoot runners run
and how well they can they can do it so
we started bringing in habitual barefoot
runners into the lab to see just to see
how they're they use their bodies and
how they use their feet all right here
we go
what we discovered was that barefoot
runners run very differently from the
way your typical shod Runner Ron so the
shoe has got a big deal it's designed to
make it very comfortable to land on your
heel and so a lot of shod runners land
on the heel all right and then they
bring them up to their foot down
so when you land again on your heel your
body comes to a dead stop there's a lot
of mass and so there's an impact is that
there's a rapid force it's it's like
somebody heating you on the heel with a
hammer about two to three times your
volume so when we started bringing
barefoot runners into the lab we
discovered that they they didn't like to
do that right they typically landed on
the front of their foot pretty
horizontally not not not not not like
that but just a little bit so that they
land underneath the heads of the fourth
and fifth metatarsal often and then they
bring the heel down and when we ran over
fourth place we discovered that they
didn't have that big spike that impacts
transient that is typically associated
with a history so what barefoot runners
tend to do is by landing more towards
the front of the foot and then letting
the he'll come down afterwards and what
that does is it converts the energy that
would otherwise be a dead stop right a
vertical deceleration of the leg it
converts that into rotational energy you
can understand the difference with the
following very commonplace observation
imagine dropping the pin onto the ground
but falling vertically dumb that's like
a heel strike but the entire leg strike
the ground and comes to stop into the
big impact for
on the other hand if you're a forefoot
strike then you can think of it like the
pen landing at an oblique angle where it
hits a ground and it doesn't come to a
dead stop which starts rotating so not
all the energy kinetic energy of the pen
actually absorbed by the impact some of
it gets transferred from moving down to
rotation and so the impact forces are
much smaller in a forefoot strike
compared to a heel strike a lot of
runners get injured and they what they
get typically often are repetitive
stress injuries and so one hypothesis is
that that impact caused by landing on
the heel which causes that big impact
transient could be injurious and it's
associated with pain in the soft tissues
at the bottom of the foot it's
associated with shin splints may cause
some other kinds of injury so our
hypothesis is that individuals who don't
land on their heel but avoid those big
impacts by landing on the front of their
foot may be less susceptible to those
kinds of repetitive stress injuries so
we've been studying barefoot runners now
for quite a while and we went to Africa
we looked at people who've never worn
shoes and they've been running 20
kilometers a day and I just decided I
had to try running barefoot myself so I
last summer actually I was running one
day and I just decided to take my shoes
off and I I thought it was just
incredibly fun and since then I've
actually started running barefoot
frequently and actually I really love it
it feels great I've stopped heel
striking and I now I've become a
forefoot striker and and
it's one